so my wife and I are currently saving up
to buy a house um and her grandma who
she's very close to just offered to give
us a gift of $30,000 to put towards the
down payment uh my question is is is it
ethically okay to take this gifts
knowing that she has siblings cousins
and uh her parents who have not been
given that same offer of a gift it's
ethically okay um because it's not your
money it's her money she gets to decide
what she wants to do with her money and
um but what you're pointing out is is it
may piss them off yeah and kind of
justifiably so I mean because there's no
intention as far as you know for granny
to like give everybody the same amount
right yeah not not that we know of I I
think she may but don't know for sure
yeah I don't think you I don't think you
have an Ethics problem but you might
have a relationship problem when all
this comes out to light